rusia y eeuu insisten en mantener
abierta la puerta del diálogo aunque
ambos se mantienen inamovibles en sus
posturas cuál será la reacción de
vladimir putin tras considerar que sus
preocupaciones en materia de seguridad
han sido ignoradas
buenas noches mareada
yo diría que no sería correcto decir que
el oeste está ignorando las demandas de
putte es más preciso decir que el oeste
está rechazando sus demandas y eso es
bueno porque lo que estamos haciendo es
mostrar que no estamos débil si
estábamos aceptando esas demandas sería
una recompensa a putin por su es por su
agresión y eso podría permitir que putin
y rusia echarán la culpa a la ampliación
de nato de la otan y eso no sería
correcto para entonces no es decir que
estamos ignorando estamos rechazando
precisamente esa a esas demandas y más
jefes de estados llegan a ucrania para
expresar apoyo y el país anuncia un
aumento de 100.000 tropas en tres años
se acaba el tiempo para una solución
negociada a esta crisis absolutamente
hay hay tiempo para eso porque la
iniciativa está en las manos de putin la
otan y el oeste no no va a hacer nada en
termos militares más hasta que rusia
invadió
hace una agresión dentro de ucrania
porque lo que vamos a hacer en lo este
hemos dicho que si rusia lanzará un
ataque a ucrania vamos a iniciar
sanciones
entonces
no es de esas sanciones y las otras
acciones que la otan tomada serían en
reacción a una inversión entonces hay
tiempo para la negociación con rusia y
estados unidos y europa han defendido la
autonomía de la otan para decidir cuáles
son sus miembros sin cerrarle la puerta
a ucrania que implicaría si este país
entra a la alianza militar
eso es una buena pregunta porque lo que
posees hay que recordar que putin lo que
él teme más es tener un país exitoso
especialmente uno que sea que tiene un
tengo un liderazgo elegido
democráticamente a lo largo de su
frontera porque eso es mal para el resto
de los países lo que él quiere a lo que
putin quiere es una esfera de influencia
que quiere controlar
y la ucrania en los otros países a lo
largo de frontera con el oeste entonces
lo que nosotros tenemos que hacer es
mantener la posición porque si nosotros
aceptamos las concesiones o damos
concesiones a rusia vamos a hacer débil
y él va a
pedir a aumentar sus demandas para otras
cosas